like we need some energy I go I go when
I say stun set I want everybody to go
and I swear on on like during the take I
go stud set and all the like 7 foot
basketball players oh and the Japanese
guys were like
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh welcome back everybody to a very very
special episode of off the Record where
we're doing
an unscripted collab with us media today
oh wow today we've got Mr Jeremy and
Nick the funniest guy in the [__]
room Nick the ear [__] you dude all
right damn doing a o o o say it again o
o media did you did you do cin or
something no oh is that where it's from
no no no tell them what o means oh so so
I mean O is just like it's Japanese it's
like a general thing the funny thing is
they don't even say it over there uh
some yeah I mean it's it's a old like my
parent my dad's generation when they say
what's up blue collared guys say it to
each blue collared guys say to each
other as a if you're at a if you're at a
construction site or whatever you'll see
like like those guys fishermen like
tough dudes like it's like real like you
know like a man's man of saying what's
up yeah our old MMA gy used to do it cuz
he has a his karate style is like
us be a fish but it's that style it was
smell like tuna in there but when you
when you go to those gyms everyone says
o yeah we went inside you walked in and
when that walked yeah shokan guys don't
do it oh cuz they're like University
guys they're like different they're like
classy right so like it's just it's just
a greeting like saying what's up but
Mass like Macho dudes but do you have to
laugh it's like respect or you just like
walk by o like that o o
I did that to Tyrone Woodley one time I
saw him like coming out of a cafe he saw
us and I think a couple of one of us was
wearing the rash guard so he did this
like he did this like ah don't [__]
talk to me like kind of thing he was
like that and we were walking past and
he you could see kind of took a side
step like that cuz you know he's like oh
these guys are probably fighter nerds
whatever and I just go who and he goes W
just keeps walking and I think he just
appreciated I didn't go like hey Tyrone
I'm big F like like and he's got to put
the face hey Tyrone you really get
knocked out by Jake Paul dude why' you
throw the fight was a lot of
money probably be doing that [__] too
man but it's like a cool like draft by
respect like it's like a v o what's up I
just remember hearing it all the time
when I went to like tricking gyms yeah
yeah any time like people would just
going off yeah they would just say it to
each other all the time well it became
like a big Trend in The Stunt World cuz
um JJ Perry who's now he's the director
of day shift or uh yeah day shift I they
keep talking about night shift right now
cuz they're working on the next one but
but he's like this Texan who came um
into the Taekwondo world like from the
Army and was like really good in the 80s
at taekwondo but like that's the
character's backstory or no no this is
the guy this is the guy JJ the
director I like this are you pitching
this movie he looks like a guy that will
just pull a shotgun out of nowhere like
he's like that southern dude but he's
like more Asian than all of us he knows
he's married to a Filipino chick he
knows more to to me sometimes he knows
more Korean from doing Taekwondo in
the80s like his kicks were dope right
and anyways on in the stunt Community
like ever since he was doing Texas
Walker range like like all the old shows
he as a morale booster he'd go stunt set
we go oh and literally like all the way
to like John Wick four you know when the
the the Japanese guys face all the tall
basketball players the basketball
players weren't stunt guys they were
just locals we found and I was like I
went up to them cuz they the first take
they had zero energy and I Coach Carter
then like brought them in and I was like
you see those Japanese guys and they're
like yeah I was like these little [__]
think they're really going to win this
[__] war and they're like huh I go
look at them and the they're like
he
like we need some energy I go I go when
I say stun set I want everybody go a and
I swear on on like during the take I go
stud set and all the like s foot
basketball players oh and the Japanese
guys were like
oh oh
[__] like it became this crazy like like
so we still use it all the time but but
in this Stunt World like JJ Perry made
it like cool as [__] oh that's cool that
there's a you can pinpoint who actually
like made it cool in the world so he
learned it in Japan no I mean he just
grew up in the he made it up in Japan
took it from him he made it seem like
you guys took it but but for our Stunt
World he made it like kind of cool right
and on on set but every sound guy on
every set is like [__] hate
this cuz they got adjust holding the boo
M they're like
[Laughter]
scoffing every time they're hella funny
but can you not and sometimes they'll
just go can you not do the thing they'll
say that and you guys do even louder
I'll be yeah I'll be like this time
we're going to go
louder that's dope though when everyone
does like a a war cry together good yeah
United y yeah like when you say [__]
hakas I don't think you'll get in
trouble for that at Alla Chaka M want
hugi over here dude and you see the
other like poor rugby team like we're
going to get
mold dude have you seen them do it at
like their weddings and like the wives
like the wives are just like falling and
they you know they [__] Brothers
they're [__] going off that's pretty
gangster dude it's super that's one of
the few things that you'll see like
cross culturally and be like I wish we
had that [__] yeah cuz you don't you
don't be the other team that's just
standing there like not getting the air
time yeah yeah you just see like 12
other Edge shearing over there we're
going to get [__] up it but it does
suck to be like a team that's that's
displaying that and everyone's like whoa
and then you get
smoked yeah that's the worst do you ever
see the the NBA I think it was like a
you set the bar so high the
international basketball uh League I
guess it's like a Team USA so they have
all the best Superstars and they're
watching I think the New Zealand team
and they're doing the the the Haka or
whatever and they're just like the you
see James Harden like Kevin Durant like
what the [__] is going on and they
probably dropped like 50 on them oh my
God it's it's it's we have the best
player in the world it's like you're not
going to beat James Harden and LeBron
James yeah that's pretty funny but they
also got [__] like ASAP Berg in the
[__]
headphon yeah that's their that's their
Haka yeah you're like and those guys the
New Zealand guys were like that's
actually pretty cool too might we steal
some of that who idea was it to call the
the uh Network o Jeremy marinas that
your idea let's go yeah I mean the the
we were just going on for a week and I
just kept saying o o and then I was like
what if we just said oo o and we were
like o what and then and then Ben was
like the marketers Us
Media I was like and he was like what
does O mean I'm like I don't know man
it's a
Vibe I could be like o and I could be
like
o I use it I overuse it Universal
Martial Arts term though if you do
martial arts you understand what it
heard that you and I think people I
think like randomly I've seen like
channels that i' never seen before had
tried to do o like there was like o
films or OSU and then there was like an
o TV but like they're just not
cool TV fcking nerd ass guy like like we
we tried to We spelled it like in a way
where a logo could be clean you could
like see it on a shirt and you're like
what is that like is that donut media
like you know what I mean like so we
just try to like make it not so like hey
we do Marshall Arts take it seriously
like we try to have fun yeah you guys
write it OSS so then it's not o
we like the oo yeah we want your lips to
do this
oo yeah cuz if you wrote it in English
it would be OS SS u o o or yeah o o s
but that's not cool not cool that's lame
dude but that's how the Japanese stole
it from that one texting guy and then
they tried to change it like
colonization exactly change this old
scroll fun fact said they made it up
boxing came to uh Japan before karate
did isn't that interesting well Japan
has some really good boxers though he
just ruined my life Jack what ruin my
life start crying I mean it's been in
Oka for ages but it was called Chinese
hands so boxing is Chinese notes Chinese
box yeah yeah no and then uh Jack
Dempsey was getting really popular and
Japan was like going oh [__] boxing sick
right because they didn't have um
striking it was all just Jiu-Jitsu Judo
it's it was the same thing at the time
and then the the government was like oh
[__] we can't let this America craze
like you know we're trying to be like at
the time they didn't enter World War II
yet so they're trying to make like
Japanese Pride [__] right yeah cuz now
they're all about
baseball they let that happen you know
the Japanese brought baseball to America
right crazy D but the founder of Judo he
he found he basically got jiujitsu and
then did all the and made it a sport he
he took out all the deadly [__] he made
and he and then so the the the
government went to him and said can you
find a striking art they found it in
Okinawa and then at the time they call
it Chinese hands so they were just like
well we can't make it Chinese can we no
no no and then so they go all you guys
come up with the form that's just
striking we don't need all that
grappling [__] we already have a
grappling art so they took out all the
grappling in the okina and karate and
then they made shaon yeah sick that's
why it's so
like yeah yeah they should call it Blue
Zone karate Blue Zone karate oh that
would be sick I just love the fact 100 I
love the fact that he was like can you
find us a thing and he comes back and
goes I got it it's Chinese hands like
are you trying to piss me off Yuki we
can't call it that that's why they're
like Yuki huh and we're going to call it
empty hands Yuki baby I can't work with
this come
on ain't it crazy though once I found
that cuz even my ass I mean we would
watch these [__] martial art films
and and think it's this ancient Japanese
thing like yeah and it's like Pride of
the country right and then like you
[__] study the [__] out of it and you
go oh [__] this is just Kung
Fu this just [__] Kung Fu bro in the
credits it goes karate played by Kung Fu
oh like this is literally just Shaolin
Kungfu that just it's like Japanese
ramen people think it's OG it's Chinese
food but it's been in Japan for so long
they just did their own thing you like
some Italian who looks just like you
thinking like looking at spaghetti going
[__] they put they put soup in ramen
this is noodle this is uh SOA noodles I
thought this was a pride of
[Laughter]
Italy yeah fun fact so tell us more
about o we got both you guys here well
Jeremy does the stunt side and they do
some really cool stuff um they do these
challenges where they'll try to recreate
a fight scene in like like 15 minutes or
something crazy you watch it and shoot
it as you when I watch you guys well
they some of the stunt guys they did
this um they did like a a parody of
Arthur the cartoon of a fight scene and
I never knew what the whole process was
to shoot and choreograph a fight scene
and it was really cool to see they do
this thing called previs where they just
like kind
of yeah they map everything out and then
they have to use like a IP ad or just
like a iPhone to like get the shots the
way they want to and I was like man for
a 15 maybe like a minute fight scene
it's it it takes like 12 hours of just
doing the previous and then they have to
like edit everything so all the work
that goes into like kind of like Bart
said all the work that goes into the
fight stunt stuff is really cool to see
I think I'm personally fascinated by it
because I love the martial arts movies
and all that so to see the process is
really cool especially with [__] the
the guys who are you know pioneering
this stuff right now and and with it's
just like a fight in the sense that like
a lot of a lot of stunt people will kind
of do the previous half ass CU they oh
well it's not the shoot day so it
doesn't matter well the harder you train
in training the better you're going to
be at fighting right so the more
preparation you do in your previous work
when you come to the day as long as
every department is on the same page you
just shoot it out and it's an easy 8
hour day so that's what we use that's
what we use preis for and and I think us
in general is just like a a middle
ground for the the real martial artists
right of the world and the Stunt Man
martial artist to like come together at
the table and educate people on like you
know cuz I I've always wanted to be
doing like conversations like this where
okay real martial artist and stunt
martial artists like um review this
fight scene and cuz you know I'm a real
martial artist too I hang out with real
martial art and they go why didn't they
just do this why didn't they just do
that and then you know on the stunt side
you're like you don't know that the
meetings I'm having with a director who
just learned caga so they wanted to be
caga you know or somebody who just
learned an armar and like every movie
since 2008 has had an armar in it so I
don't want to do it but the D the the
producer just learned an armar so they
want to see an armar and like you can
choreograph whatever you want or ho
Berry's arm doesn't bend that way so we
got to do this other thing oh and then
there you know I heard like um one of my
friends who was working on Fast 7 they
choreographed this thing with Ronda
where they'll put Rhonda in a armar and
then she turns around and armbars them
but then Rhonda apparently at the time
was like I won't even let you
choreograph me being armbarred because I
don't get
armbarred things like that right like
which is to her respect if that's her
Legacy right she armar people so so
she's like on set I don't want to get
armbarred and in your brain as a fan you
would be like it would be sick in a
scripted fight to see Rhonda almost get
arm and then turn around and say this is
how it actually happened it has a little
drama to it but Ronda was like no you
can't even damn that's a shame because
that that makes it cool yeah yeah but
she's like not even you can't even
imagine it yeah or you get into like you
get into these rooms where like you have
a guy who doesn't do martial arts film
per se fighting a martial art Legend and
they're like the the actor is like a big
dude and the Legend's like a little you
know Asian guy and like the Asian guy's
like I'm the martial art Legend I'm not
going to lose to him the big guy's like
ah but I'm like 63 and I'm I'm a so and
so I'm not going to lose to him so then
you have to like choreograph away for
them to both win or both lose or like
somebody interrup that's how it goes
down but how about how about like Tyson
and and and [__] itman and Tyson yeah
see they're like they're two legends
Legends but he's like I'm the weel boxer
here I could beat everybody up like I
want to break all those windows but see
in that in that sense like like I smoke
weed now so it's all good
man but in that sense it's easy cuz
Donnie was like he's like he's a real
boxer and he's a legend he's like he's
sick man it it can go either way and and
then he just like finds a way to
choreograph it for it to work for
everybody so everyone's happy yeah
that's rough too when people have signed
on to a film on certain conditions yeah
uh I thought we talked about this he's
like but you're the villain you can't
win no I'm the fighter it's like it's
doesn't work that way bro it doesn't
make sense what about at the end of this
movie the good guy has to win like I
want to shoot itman but I'm
65 you know that's impossible 65 guys
don't
die uh he's right [__] kids dude it's
like the funny thing to me is like it's
adults playing kid pretend ground prend
that's true I shot you I shot you dude
they're so serious I you so serious
about it and no no no times out times
out time out I [__] killed you bro
bfield bfield and that's my whole thing
is like uh uh in the even in the movie
World they try to find ways to uh make
film making like this mysterious thing
yeah and then action it's like and and
for me I'm like we just never grew up
and we just put it on camera now and
we're just having fun so why try to make
martial arts or film making too serious
but like why don't we use this medium of
YouTube like in a place where people who
don't understand that side of it right
or or some people can explain to real
real martial artists and then vice versa
like a real martial artist can go I
would have done this and the stun guy
would have been like I wasn't mature
enough in my career in my in my creative
brain to think of that damn I'll use it
in the next one and yeah you know a dope
Bridge so when you guys have real
martial artists like David so on um
doing commentary with you guys like well
was that is that a different thing you
guys are doing for well we we started an
MMA podcast because I think just the
format of talking about MMA is a lot
easier and longer form so we'll do we'll
we'll talk about the fights upcoming cuz
people really like those conversations
and D you know David David could talk
[__] about everything but he also is a
fight nerd so he he really Dives deep so
that's where it's like it's fun yeah
he's entertaining he talks some [__] he
got some hot takes it's fun that's great
and then um yeah so like the MMA Combat
Sports World with the stunt world is a
pretty cool combo because like Jeremy
people might look at Jeremy and be like
oh he's just a stunt guy but he's like a
legit [__] martial artist who said
that about him man uh Anthony
Lee an Lee said that bro wait he did but
as far but as take my goddamn name out
your godamn don't slap me dude but as
far as like what Jeremy does like he is
probably the most well-rounded in the
aspect of tricking striking even
training people who are like beginners
it you know to do this giant crazy fight
scene that you guys have to do all the
time that takes months of work on top of
him being an actual legit jitu guy so
it's like he could do it all what's Nick
amazing at by the way not stun his ears
are so cool and he's really funny
there's good handles [__] funniest oh
what we about say Nick is funny don't
let him grab you what if I just now
picture Nick putting you like in a like
a whole not not a submission but like
just making you laugh uncontrollably
like just I might dry hump you a little
bit have you guys sparred no we haven't
you should because do it right now as an
experienced martial artist when I
sparred with uh Nick he made me feel
very cuddly and warm killing me yeah
you'll like you'll enjoy your last
breath and then you're like yeah dude
Jeremy does some stuff on his Instagram
where I rewind it like a million times
I'm like how the [__] did he do that but
it's like a script Nick does stuff where
he just like deflects it immediately and
I'm like how the [__] did he do that no
but seriously like like uh the stunt the
the jiujitsu the the traditional
jiujitsu techniques you do and then you
turn them into almost like I guess a St
make it more camera movie action yeah
movie action like I'm like how the [__]
do you guys even come up with that cuz
you guys are doing spins and rolls that
I'm like I didn't even know you could do
that oh dude you should we've been
nerding out this last couple weeks and
and I can't say what it is or what we're
doing but like if you stop Never Back
Down seven no blood sport 5
seven 23 well there has to be a time
where the two branches of Us Media train
with each other and that'll be fun I've
been trying to get them to do it I know
I've been trying to tell Gil too but we
got to bring what are the branches well
cuz it's like the stunt world and then
like the comedy world and then Gilbert's
what he's he's with he's on our he's on
our side was that a DI no no he said the
comedy girl world but what's
Gilbert he's the comedy guy dude we got
Gilbert kickbox is we got to Branch
together and like do your guys' workout
like you guys got to put us through the
legendary 871 workouts because can I
come I want nah dude you can't come dude
come no we should all go we should all
go we should even do a JK thing where we
go yeah you guys just kick our [__]
ass dude for for 3 hours okay dude
you're hurting my shoulder
[Music]
what